que tá um chazinho para acalmar o Ch de
EVA cidreira da espécie milissa
oficinales é conhecido por suas
propriedades calmantes e pode ser eficaz
na redução dos sintomas existem vários
componentes da erva que ajudam a
combater o estresse a erva cidreira
contém compostos chamado de terpenos que
possuem propriedades sedativas e
ansiolíticas que controlam a ansiedade
esses compostos são capazes de relaxar o
sistema nervoso e diminui a ansiedade
aliviando os sintomas do estresse outro
componente importante do chá de herva
cidreira da espécie Melissa é o ácido
cafeico que tem propriedades
ansiolíticas e antidepressivas ele é
capaz de aumentar a produção de
serotonina e de dopamina
neurotransmissores que são responsáveis
por regular o humor e a emoção Olha que
legal essa erva também é uma fonte rica
em magnésio um mineral que é muito
conhecido por seus efeitos relaxantes no
corpo